you avant toute chose je voulais vous
remercier pour la vidéo précédente qui
vous amène un moment plus en plus d'une
vision très personnelle donc voilà je
suis encore plus heureux aujourd'hui on
va parler d'autre chose puisque pour
beaucoup d'entre nous confinement rime
avec solitude
ah c'est vrai qu'il termine 1e manche et
l'autre en étude
donc c'est pas vraiment une vraie rim
mais c'est plus dans le sens que c'est
là ils vont ensemble souvent c'était
plus ça que je voulais dire c'est assez
spécial à solitude parce que personne
d'autre que nous peut nous dire si on se
sent seul
alors que par exemple il ya plein
d'autres émotions sentiments qui se voit
qu'ils se sentent etc
mais la solitude vous pouvez être au
milieu de plein de gens qui vous aiment
et vous sentir quand même seul en fait
c'est un sentiment qui est très intime
et moi d'une certaine manière ce
confinement il m'a fait penser à
l'histoire de henry david thoreau un
philosophe américain du 19e siècle en
mars 1845 fort on commence à construire
une petite cabane de pain de 13 mètres
carrés sur les rives de l'étang de
hold'em dans le massachusetts et le 4
juillet le jour de l'indépendance
il s'y installe c'est une cabane qui est
éloigné des hommes mais en temps pas
trop non plus puisque la première maison
est à environ 1 km de kilomètres quoi
alors la question c'est pourquoi il
s'isole mais ça on sait pas trop il ya
plein de raisons c'est pas très clair
c'est c'est pour rire son bouquin c'est
aussi parce que il a malencontreusement
par accident brûler une partie de la
forêt donc pas forcément très apprécié
dans le coin et parce que c'est pas un
très grand fan du genre humain dans
cette maisonnette de 13 mètres carrés il
va rester deux ans deux mois et 2 jours
et va écrire
walden qui va profondément marqué la
littérature américaine et qui va même
créé un genre puisque c'est le nature
writing walden c'est un endroit où soro
a su se recentrer sur ce qui lui
semblait essentiel des fois je prends ce
taureau des fois je contrôle je ne sais
pas comment ça se passe mais ça je
l'avais
du coup on reprend pour la daf world
dance est un endroit où soro a pu se
recentrer sur ce qui lui semble est
essentielle un endroit où il pouvait se
concentrer s'éloigner de tout le bruit
des humains il pouvait du coup faire ce
qui était beaucoup plus dur à faire
habituellement dont écrire son livre qui
serait aussi un hommage à son frère mort
à 27 ans du tétanos qu'avec ces coupes
et en se rasant
ouais on pouvait moins fière de ça et
puis on a inventé les vaccins
heureusement que que ça existe quoi que
tout le monde
tout le monde se rend compte de la
chance qu'on a quoi de les avoir versé
marenla il en manque juste un et on voit
comme c'est la merde c'est fou j'ai pas
pu m'en empêcher
il profita aussi de cette retraite pour
lire énormément et apprendre dans une
lettre à un ami il écrit
le yogi absorbé par la contemplation
contribuer à sa façon à la création
il respire un parfum divin il entend des
choses magnifiques
d'une certaine façon à de rares
éclaircies mais moi je suis vieux et
c'est quelque chose qu'on a pu observer
aussi pendant ce confinement on a vu
l'essor de la méditation du yoga et ses
essais des activités qui souvent rime
avec solitude c'est pour ça que les
retraites méditative par exemple sont
généralement des retraites silencieuse
où l'on est seul je vous lis une autre
citation de faro que j'aime bien je suis
partie vivre dans les bois
parce que je voulais vivre en toute
intentionnalité me confronter aux
données essentielles de la vie et voir
si je pouvais apprendre ce qu'elle avait
à m'enseigner plutôt que de constater au
moment de mourir je n'avais point b q
est ce intéressant parce que dans notre
esprit il y a quelque chose de glorieux
de courage à cette solitude là alors que
la solitude d'un enfant à qui personne
ne parle dans la cour de récré bas et
fait un petit peu de la peine c'est la
différence entre la solitude qui est
subi et la solitude qui est choisie en
anglais ils ont loneliness qui est
teintée de tristesse et solitude qui
respire la réflexion et je pense que ce
deuxième mots nous manquent
parce que ces deux états qui n'ont rien
à voir et du coup vu qu'on n'a que le
mot solitude et bien il a un petit peu
une mauvaise connotation or la solitude
on en a besoin elles nécessaires elle
est nécessaire à la réflexion à nous
donne l'occasion de contempler nos
actions et de développer notre
conscience et je suis pas le seul qui le
dit il ya une philosophe dont de mémoire
je n'ai jamais parlé sur cette chaîne
est
vraiment je pensais pas le faire sur un
sujet comme la solitude c'est hannah
arendt
alors c'est une émigrée juive allemande
qui a fui le nazisme et qui a trouvé
refuge aux états unis elle même ne se
considère pas vraiment comme philosophe
mais plutôt politologue et elle a
travaillé toute sa vie sur le lien entre
l'individu et la cité avec notamment un
focus sur le totalitarisme
mais au cours de son travail elle s'est
aussi penché sur la solitude et elle a
écrit ceci être avec soi même et juger
par soi-même s'articuler sexualise dans
le processus de pensée et chaque
processus de pensée est une activité au
cours de laquelle je me parle de ce qui
se trouve me concernait le mode
d'existence les présents dans ce
dialogue silencieux
je l'appellerai maintenant solitude la
solitude représente donc davantage que
les autres modes d'être seul en
particulier surtout les seulement et
d'isolement et elle est différente de la
solitude implique que bien que seul je
sois avec quelqu'un c'est à dire moi
même elle signifie que je suis deux ans
non comme le jambon
cette réflexion sur la solitude et ce
qu'elle implique elle est d'autant plus
importante dans notre monde qui est
hyper connectés et où on n'est jamais
vraiment seul moi je me souviens j'ai dû
traverser la moitié de la terre
m'enfermer dans un temple avec des
moines qui ont pris tout ce que j'avais
pour pouvoir ressentir ce que cherchait
c'était peut-être un peu extrême jeu
peut-être pas obligé de faire tout ça
mais en tout cas c'est très dur quoi
c'est assez dur dans le monde je trouve
de ressentir truc là c'est important de
rappeler que ce n'est pas parce que la
solitude bonne et nécessaire à la
réflexion qu'elle implique la solitude
mauvaise c'est pas parce qu'on
réfléchisse qu'on s'isole un
souvenez-vous la caverne de platon
le philosophe c'est celui qui sort de la
caverne seul et qui accède au monde des
idées mais ne fait pas que contempler le
monde des idées tout seul il en fait
profiter la cité parce que oui toucher à
cette solitude et en jouir c'est quelque
chose qu'on va pas faire seulement pour
nous mais aussi pour les autres avant
d'être avec les autres il faut pouvoir
être avec soi même et c'est quelque
chose qui est vraie à tous les niveaux
c'est vrai pour l'amitié
c'est vrai pour le couple et c'est vrai
pour la société il ya plein d'autres
niveaux mais ceux là sont ceux qui sont
le plus marquant pour cet exemple je
trouve
après walden ferro a apporté énormément
à la société il a été notamment reconnu
pour un concept qu'il a créé dans un
essai en juillet 1846
il se fait mettre en prison parce qu'il
n'a pas payé ses impôts pour protester
contre l'esclavagisme du sud et la
guerre à nagano mexicaine sauf qu'ils
passent qu'une seule nuit en prison
parce que sa tante lui payer sa caution
ce qui le rend ouf ça va et en rentrant
dans sa petite cabane qu'est-ce qui fait
il fait le premier brouillon le premier
jet en fait de ce qui va donner l'un de
ces essais les plus connus la
désobéissance civile et donc c'est lui
qui a créé le concept de désobéissance
civile en gros hannah arendt aussi à
souligner l'importance de la solitude
non pas pour soi mais pour la société en
1961 elle est commissionné par le new
yorker pour couvrir le procès d'adolphe
iceman un officier ss qui a pris pas à
l'orchestration de l'holocauste est en
fait à se demander comment c'était
possible de faire quelque chose d'aussi
monstrueux et elle se disait ya que des
psychopathes cinglé pour prendre part à
la choix impossible et en fait elle a
été surprise de voir que même si ces
actions était monstrueuse rischmann la
personne l'individu était au final assez
ordinaire quoi
l'été qui était pas démoniaque elle a
attribué son immoralité et sa capacité à
faire de tels crimes à sa forte la snes
son absence de pensée pour elle c'était
l'incapacité dajczman à s'arrêter et à
réfléchir qui avait fait de lui un
monstre pour elle si on perd notre
capacité à être seul avec nous-mêmes à
laon berne capacité à réfléchir et on
peut facilement se faire emporter
notamment par la foule et c'est
intéressant parce que sénèque dans la
vie heureuse nous dit que le chemin de
la foule n'est pas le bon il dit ça
exactement il est nuisible en effet
d'être attaché à ceux qui nous précèdent
chacun préférant croire plutôt que juger
on ne porte jamais de jugement sur la
vie on est toujours dans la croyance est
l'erreur transmise de main en main nous
remue en tous sens et nous mène à notre
ruine nous périssons par l'exemple des
autres nous guérirons pour peu que nous
nous séparions de la foule
c'est donc aussi ça la solitude c'est
pas que pour se développer soi c'est
aussi pour développer
société mais un contraste que je trouve
super intéressant euros bah c'était pas
un pacifiste il a soutenu par exemple le
raid armé de l'abolitionniste john
browne et quand john drogue a été pendue
soro a fait un discours hyper fois sous
un drapeau américain renverser ce qui
est un gros signe de contestation
et pourtant et pourtant à walden vous
trouverez rien d'autre que la sérénité
du calme
c'est un endroit paisible et l'essence
de tout ce que je viens de vous dire
réside dans ce contrat cela ferait 10
est aussi je ne me suis jamais senti
seul ou du moins oppressés par un
sentiment de solitude
sauf une fois c'était quelques semaines
après mon arrivée dans la forêt quand
pendant une heure je suis demandé si le
voisinage proche des hommes n'était pas
essentielle à une vie sereine et en
bonne santé
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
j'espère que ça vous a intéressé
moi je voulais vous parler de forro est
en fait en creusant le sujet ça
paraissait évident de parler de hannah
arendt aussi et voilà ça fait une vidéo
un petit peu plus étoffé que ce que
j'avais prévu
mais c'est pas plus mal mais voilà je
voulais juste vous parlez de 9 euros de
la solitude et à quel point la solitude
est importante
à quel point on
on a une mauvaise image de ces solitudes
là et je pense pour les mauvaises
raisons
et voilà je pense que il faut changer
notre lien à cette solitude là et la
cultiver davantage
voilà je trouvais que cette vidéo elle
était importante à sortir avant la vidéo
que je vais faire sur sur les autres
addictions au téléphone parce que voilà
l'addiction au téléphone aussi nous
empêche d'accéder à cette solitude si
muzeau qui est très important pour moi
donc voilà sera la prochaine vidéo de
cette chaîne normalement donc si ce
n'est pas le cas abonnez vous je suis un
débrief de cette vidéo là tout de suite
sur tweets je prends tv slash cyrus
north l'ancien débrief que j'avais fait
sur ma précédente vidéo pardon c'était
ouf genre la soirée c'était dingue
vous étiez enfin bon on a dépassé les 10
mille follower par exemple sur twitter
donc ça fait vraiment plaisir je
continue mes lectures
donc là on est toujours en train de lire
schopenhauer on a quasiment fini et je
pense que l'on va passer on va penser à
un autre bouquin après voilà ça va
continuer valoir d'autres choses les
méditations et continuent pour l'instant
elles sont que guy dès maintenant le
mardi le jeudi et à ceux en méditation
libre le lundi le mercredi et le
vendredi
voilà donc encore merci pour le soutien
merci également aux types heures je vous
remercie pas à chaque vidéo c'est vrai
je devrais le faire clairement je sais
pas je gens parlent rarement sur ma
chaîne parce que
c'est pas un truc avec lequel je suis
hyper à l'aise vous savez et
de vous demander de soutenir le projet
mais voilà si l'envié vous prend de
soutenir le projet de cette chaîne est
ce qu'elle devient parce qu'elle est en
train de changer un petit peu j'ai
l'impression 1 c'est vraiment ce que je
dis ça comme si j'en étais pas le mettre
j'en suis pas totalement le m je crois
ça serait intéressant de faire une vidéo
l'air voilà si vous avez envie de
soutenir le projet ce sera avec grand
plaisir et j'ai fait aussi dernière
chose un discorde
c'est un endroit où on peut parler des
plantes salons de discussion on peut
parler de plein de choses on peut
échanger sur plein de sujets voilà le
lien et en descriptions love peace ciao